today we're gonna be looking at the
Queen and the Queen is the most powerful
piece on the chessboard and it's worth
nine pawns equivalent to a ruika Bishop
and upon two bishops in a night two
nights in a bishop you can tell it's
very powerful if we look at the moves
that the Queen can make that the Queen
is essentially a bishop and a rook
combined they can move horizontally
vertically as many spaces as it can
without hopping over peace remember the
nice the only piece that can hop over
peace and they can also go diagonally as
many spaces as it can if you look at the
diagram as you can tell an open space
the Queen can move around much more the
Queen is really good when you think
about as far as development the Queen is
really good supporting other pieces when
you look at the beginning of a chess
game you really don't want to bring out
your queen too early you really want to
have it
supporting your other pieces some one of
the common mistakes people make in
starting out the chess game and they try
to bring their Queen out too early and
this is just a common mistake you may
see something that looks like this just
a basic example
butwhy starts with E 4 and black
responds with d5 and after white
captures black recaptures with his Queen
bringing out his Queen a little too
early we can now gain the tempo by
bringing our Knight to c3 gaining a
tempo meaning that we're developing and
forcing our opponent to lose time
meaning he's gonna have to move the same
piece again while he should be
developing other pieces let's say black
moves his Queen to g5 we can now bring
our knight to f3 attacking the Queen and
again gaining another tempo we're
developing our pieces and black Sunday
evenings running around with his queen
let's say he moves back to h6 we can
develop another piece our pawn to d4 and
it were again attacking with our bishop
let's say he moves to f6 we can now
bring our bishop into the action attack
the Queen he can't take our bishop
because we have our Knight here on F 3
defending it
let's say he moves to f5 we can bring on
another Bishop into the action to d3 and
we're just chasing the Queen around too
many beginners have the mistake of
bringing out the Queen early and trying
to have some fancy trap but when it
doesn't fall through when it doesn't
come to fruition the other team is just
going to have a lot of the veldt pieces
and the Queen is going to be running all
over the board so you don't want to do
this another thing you want to keep in
mind is if your opponent is bringing
their Queens to the action early you
simply want to develop your pieces you
don't want to basically do what the
other side wants you to do and that's
fall for trap too many people make an
incorrect move because you're only
looking at the Queen just simply develop
your pieces let the Queen run around
don't worry about too much and in the
end if you look at this position why
it's clearly better off all their pieces
are developed we can Castle kingside we
can get our Queen involved Black has
none of their pieces developed all we
were doing is simply develop our pieces
central squares like before we're not
developing our pieces to a3 with our
knight and h3 with our Knight chasing
around the Queen the incorrect way we're
simply developing to the center like
normal and at the same time we're
chasing around the Queen that's the
right way to do it the wrong way to do
it is go into abstract squares trying to
chase the Queen around so the Queen is
very good at supporting roles as you see
here the Queen came out and tried to do
all the attacking by itself
the Queen is not very good at attacking
simply by itself what you want to do is
have the Queen stay back a little bit so
in a regular game you may see
let's say both sides open up with their
nights baby a roy lopez opening here and
as you can see we're simply developing
like normal and i'm just these are just
standard moves that you'll see here both
sides castling we're getting central
control king safety here opening the
lines up and yes the move order can
change a lot and then we're going to
bring our queen in we want our queens
who support our other pieces first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna bring our
queen to square like e two we want to
connect our rooks on the back row and
our queen is really good at supporting
our minor pieces so right now we're
supporting our bishop on d2 and our
knight on f3 if there's a long diagonal
for bishop you a lot of times what your
queen behind it to support it so that if
someone were to take that bishop then
you can now defend that by recapturing
whatever piece that is so if this pawn
wasn't here on d3 we would be supporting
this bishop on d5 you always want to
have your queen supporting different
pieces again we're also supporting this
pawn on evil right now you want to have
your queen supporting pieces in the
beginning later on down the road where
some pieces are off the board then the
queen can do a lot of attacking but at
the beginning you really want to keep it
back and you want to have it do more of
a supporting role you don't want your
queen out in the middle and have it be
chased around because then you can't get
your other pieces developed when all
your minor pieces are developed you have
a strong attack then you can use the
Queen to increase that attack and then
you can get the Queen involved in the
attack so make sure a couple things you
know that the queen is the most
important well many times when you
promote your pawns to the eighth-ranked
and you can change to any piece you're
going to be changing to the Queen so you
definitely want to be familiar with it
you want to make sure that at the
beginning you keep it back
when you develop it you're developing it
to support your other pieces in light
later on you bring their Queens to the
action to help me attack out so hope
this helped with the Queen and join your
chess game thanks for watching